[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission pour
vous présenter les projets culturels
yvelinois au programme aujourd'hui
encore une semaine pour profiter du mois
molière de versailles pour la 25e
édition du festival près de 50
spectacles différents sont organisées
dans plusieurs lieux de la ville
objectif rendre la culture accessible à
tous le festival l'estival est maintenu
il se prépare pour une 34e édition les
l'île dumet karcher et poissy ont
souhaité continuer à porter le projet le
rendez vous musical met en avant les
jeunes artistes le poids sur les
concerts de mousser et puis le mobilier
national nationale présente deux
expositions à poissy la villa savoye
accueille des sièges moderne pour la
maison de faire ce sont des objets
autour de la thématique le design de
métal dont les découvrirez dans cette
émission et je vous le disais en titre
il vous reste encore une semaine pour
profiter du mois molière de versailles
si la manifestation avait été annulée
l'année dernière en raison de la crise
sanitaire
la 25e édition du festival est maintenue
au mois de juin
la 25e édition propose une diversité de
spectacles dans plusieurs lieux de la
ville objectif rendre la culture
accessible à tous la ville de versailles
s'est transformé en théâtre à ciel
ouvert le temps du mois de juin
objectif proposer des rendez vous
culturels accessibles à tous à travers
la ville près de 50 spectacles sont
organisés dans plusieurs lieux de la
cité comme les grandes écuries ou encore
l'académie internationale des arts du
théâtre
vous avez également le jardin des
musiciens y tenir où il ya des concerts
le land organise mai et puis vous avez
aussi un théâtre privé à versailles
notre volonté toujours a été de d'avoir
des spectacles de qualité qui sont
accessibles à tous le domaine des grands
chênes fait partie des lieux du festival
au programme une série de spectacles
dédiés aux arts du spectacle vivant
les déchets tfa les multiplexes de
théâtre
vie quatre ailiers qui sont cultivés
dans les mêmes étapes et avec les
spectacles choix classique quechua comme
tpo rennais choix des mimes et tous les
tous les théâtres une bonne opportunité
pour les jeunes comédiens de l'académie
internationale des arts du spectacle
une édition particulière qui leur permet
de jouer davantage
l'an dernier le molière ont joué que le
week end est là avec qu'ovide toute
restrictions sanitaires le molière s'est
restreint à l'aide à ces deux autres
lieux dans versailles et du coup nous a
dit bah on va en profiter on va jouer
tous les jours donc on joue encore plus
qu'avant
objectif de l'événement rendre la
culture accessible à tous plusieurs
milliers de spectateurs ont déjà profité
de l'occasion
si nous en avions la disponibilité nous
participerions bien sûr en tant que
spectateur bien plus souvent que
qu'aujourd'hui mais ce n'est qu'un début
c'est vraiment une très belle
opportunité de faire jouer et découvrir
les jeunes comédiens pour que c'est une
opportunité vraiment de découvrir un
certain nombre de pièces
on n'irait pas forcément voir soi-même
au théâtre encore une vingtaine de
spectacles à venir parmi lesquels carmen
la vie parisienne ou encore les
travailleurs de la mer plus
d'informations sur le site de la ville
et parmi les autres spectacles à venir
dans les yvelines le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en partenariat
avec le musée national de port royal des
champs et lons 2 vous propose une
adaptation et des trois mousquetaires un
spectacle du collectif 49 1701 qui
emprunte les codes de séries télé ça se
passera au musée national de port royal
des champs les 26 et 27 juin prochains
du 1er juillet au 1er août un festival
de musique aura lieu au potager du roi
de versailles à plusieurs concerts sont
attendus par jour c'est agathe saint
gobain soir soit vous êtes avec nous
donc c'est un événement qui met à
l'honneur la musique classique
oui ce sera la deuxième édition est
idéale au potager du roy une série de
concerts de musique classique
il y en a 37 qui sont donnés surtout
pour
encourager les jeunes talents qui n'ont
pas travaillé depuis longtemps qu'on
était quand même très atteints dans la
khl et sanitaires qui sont arrêtés et
dans l'expression
donc c'est comme une revivent ans de
leur art il y aura combien de musiciens
bien se seront 70 musiciens qui seront
présents qui donneront un des concerts
inédits comme le coiffeur à rhodes ou
encore le quatuor en scène qui
reprendront des oeuvres de tchaïkovski
ou d'amis
[Musique]
et la programmation est variée puisque
ce seront autant de jeunes talents que
d'artistes de renom le premier concert
aura lieu le 1er juillet avec gérard
depardieu qui chante barbara
écoutez un extrait
d
[Musique]
ou reviendras tu
pour moi il y six tués
tout au long du mois des conférences sur
le thème de la musique et l'europe
seront également proposés quelques
célébrités se prend deux se produiront
aussi sur la scène et du potager du roy
gérard depardieu carla bruni qui vient
pour la première fois qui a accepté
d'avoir un petit secteur à cordes autour
d'elle il ya aussi fanny ardant qui va
dire un texte de laurence place des
perplexe et va donc une histoire d'amour
du xviiie siècle
j'imagine que ces concerts sont
accessibles à tous oui ils sont bien sûr
ouvert à tous pour les moins de 12 ans
les concerts sont même gratuits et des
tarifs réduits elles sont proposées aux
moins de 25 ans
c'est une grande grande d'apprentissage
la musique mais c'est très accessible et
c'est un art je vous le répète qu est
accessible à tous on veut enchères à
barreaux ce compliqué il faut bel opéra
fois mais le chant fabuleux cadeau c'est
pas beau ça vous ouvre l'esprit les
billets de concerts donnent aussi accès
également à des visites guidées au
potager du roi pour retrouver toutes les
informations pratiques
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci célia gars tsongo d'abord été avec
nous journaliste pour la tv 78 il y aura
bien une 34e édition du festival
l'estival si la ville de saint germain
en laye a bien annoncé arrêter cette
collaboration pour créer son propre
festival
trois autres villes ont souhaité
continuer à porter le projet le pet
karcher et poissy un festival de musique
qui met en avant donc les jeunes
artistes est cette année le festival est
organisé au profit de l'association de
bénévoles du centre hospitalier
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye plusieurs
concerts sont prévus regarder sur le
théâtre de poids si on aura des gens
comme kenji girac claudio capéo maxime
le forestier ou carla bruni sur d'autres
salles un petit peu plus petit opecst ou
hr on aura trois cafés gourmands ou mr
mat et puis on aura dans chaque ville
les programmations en extérieur sur la
place de la république sur la place du
marché
autre événement dans les yvelines
jusqu'au 27 juin vous pourrez participer
aux maisons laffitte jazz festival de
nombreux concerts au programme de cet
événement musical
la 17e édition prend ses quartiers cette
année dans le jardin du château de
maison à maison laffitte et réservations
via le site qui s'affiche direction
poissy maintenant avec une exposition
globale sur deux sites différents et ce
jusqu'au 26 septembre est la villa
savoye accueille des sièges moderne à
tandis que la maison de faire des objets
autour de la thématique le design de
métal et des collections qui sont issus
du mobilier national les détails de
nicolas landry la villa savoye en état
de siège
pas d'inquiétude il s'agit d'une
exposition de fauteuils de la chaise
caddie à la chaise longue face à face en
passant par le fauteuil à bascule 20
pièces au total issues de la collection
du mobilier national
une exposition baptisée siège moderne
des sièges à la fois des années 60 au
ras du sol très bas qui montre une
nouvelle façon de s'asseoir dans ces
années là où des sièges beaucoup plus
contemporain en fibre de lin en fibre de
carbone qui montre le savoir faire dans
le les matériaux composites
pour rappel la villa savoye été
construite par le corbusier pierre
jeanneret entre 1928 et 1931 avec une
fonction de lieu de vie pour les époux
sabour l'exposition actuelle s'inscrit
dans les lieux de la ville à savoir de
façon à proposer une forme de dialogue
entre la halle architecture iconiques
que représente la ville à savoir
aujourd'hui mais de rappeler aussi sa
fonction d'invitation sa fonction d'
usage à quelques pas de la villa savoye
la maison de fer accueille l'exposition
intitulée le design de métal le lien du
coup avec l'exposition mobilier de
design et le design de métal notamment
ailier bien évidemment matériaux de
construction de la maison de faire mais
également à la valorisation des
savoir-faire de l'atelier de création et
de recherche du mobilier national
dix projets conçus en métal par
l'atelier de recherche et de création
fer de lance de la créativité au sein du
mobilier national des oeuvres finaliser
des prototypes ou encore des plans c'est
le cas des lustres conçu pour le
restaurant du loup située à abu dhabi ou
encore de cette console aux courbes
d'acier
on console qui a été conçu par olivier
védrine en inox martelé qui montre un
petit peu tout le savoir-faire de
l'atelier puisque martelé de l'inox
c'est une gageur en termes techniques et
donc une grande prouesse qui montre le
savoir faire des ateliers de l'atelier
de recherche et de création
le mobilier national prend ces assises
de métal à poissy entre la villa savoye
et la maison de fer jusqu'au 26
septembre
[Musique]
depuis le 19 juin et jusqu'au 10 juillet
l'exposition regards 3d sur objets d'art
est visible au quartier des antiquaires
de versailles à l'occasion de re
découvrir ce quartier à travers une
exposition miroir entre les oeuvres
d'origine et le ré interprétation en
impression 3d
le reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude bérengère bourgoin et juliette
prejean regarder des objets d'art
dessinée est revisité au travers du
digital c'est ce que propose l'artiste
william rolland avec son exposition
regards 3d sur objets d'art avec les
cats et des antiquaires de versailles
nous avons monté une exposition qui vise
à revisiter des objets d'art à travers
la technique que j'utilise qu'ils aient
l'impression 3d les algorithmes digitaux
l'idée c'est de ce n'est pas de faire
des reproductions des objets d'art mais
c'est bien de récupérer la matière
première de l'histoire qu'il raconte les
havres présentés sont variés effet en
matériaux biodégradables masques
africains globes terrestres ou encore
bijoux le but raconter l'histoire de ces
objets d'art et du quartier des
antiquaires
j'utilise pour pour
dans un premier temps une technique de
scanner 3d j'ai numérisé les objets on
les a choisis
avec les avec chacun des marchands en
adéquation avec leur potentiel par
rapport à ma ligne de direction
artistique
une partie du travail de l'artiste est
visible dans une galerie
douze oeuvres originales ont été créés
pour cette exposition dispersés dans le
quartier des antiquaires
on a créé cet événement dans l'esprit
d'une balade où on vient redécouvrir le
quartier
il faudra alléger surtout surtout le
quartier dans chaque vitrine essaie de
retrouver le l'oeuvre au fond restera
bien en évidence
on trouvera en vitrine les la version
originale on va dire historique et puis
la version retravaillée
les créations de cette exposition seront
disponibles à la vente en série limitée
de neuf exemplaires et autres
expositions visibles en ce moment
mythologie noir entre réflexion autour
de la peau noire et perception
culturelle affective ou raciales de
l'artiste cette exposition regroupe
trois séries de photos réalisées par
philippe niort entre 2005 et 2020
elle est à découvrir les jeudis
vendredis samedis et dimanches jusqu'au
11 juillet au centre d'exposition les
réservoirs deux lits mais et c'est la
fin de cette émission du 7-8 culture
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi pour une nouvelle
émission et d'ici là portez vous bien
[Musique]